confiance coin jean - ce
laisse moi veillez surtout plus l'ajout
du goût acheminés depuis l'europe
aujourd'hui le dès mon plus jeune âge je
peux dire que j'ai toujours
impressionner mes camarades quand
j'étais au collège parce que même jeu
par l'âge de 12 ans je préfère une très
grosse voix et les impressionner j'avais
j'avais 12 ans je t'aime petit bonhomme
comme ça je pourrais faire du tout là
bas qu'est ce que savait nous apaiser
moi quand je racontais une histoire
automatiquement les voix me venaient
j'avais beau être très jeune je vais
faire une voie de vielle aure est
complètement comme ça danse ça agrémenté
mes histoires j'étais déjà un petit peu
cabot alors j'ai vraiment aimé histoire
en colorant mes personnages de haut en
bas de l'amazone et a pas meilleur
tireur qu'est moi ou avec et d'amandes à
laval première chose on regarde d'abord
on ne sait si le rôle est très important
on visionne le film ce qui est
indispensable à mon avis pour bien jouer
un personnage
ensuite il faut savoir bien reconnaître
la couleur et éviter si possible c'est
qu'on essaie maintenant le faire au
maximum ses de trahir l'acteur qui a
joué et c'est pas fou il faut trouver
des voies qui sortent des personnages
deviennent plus troublant de voir un
acteur allemand italien ou anglais avec
une voix qui se reçoit du personnage
vous voyez même quelquefois des femmes
ravissante qui font dire images
épouvantables
parce qu'elle essaie de reproduire la
crim à ce qu'elle voit sur l'écran et ça
c'est normal et notre bien il ya des
créations doit le personnage d'astérix
par exemple là c'est nous qui avons créé
les voies avec jacques morel la série
que c'est un petit personnage qui perd
le sec
par toutatis par bélénos aa on essaie
toujours de trouver la voie qui sort
bien on enregistre une première fois une
fois que l'animation est fait et on
écoute et si on a l'impression qu'elle
avoir bien du petit personnage qu elle
est maligne voyez vous si c'est une voix
brève qui colle avec ce petit personnage
très actifs alors on se dit tiens la
voix collent mieux la voix de mickey
c'est ça m'a beaucoup séduit parce que
c'est un personnage de mon enfant
ce que j'aimais beaucoup mais comme
c'est une voix très aiguë les trayons
c'est beaucoup plus difficile et les
enfants étaient habitués à cette voie en
anglais et donc les reproduire aux
français dans les allées socha alors là
je vous ai deux personnages la souris
roquefort il petit furet qui paris a
ainsi brièvement ulrich un personnage un
peu bref comme ça et rapide
et puis le chien lafayette un groupe
l'afrique est un petit peu baveux sur
les bords et genre de charme mais pas
moi j'ai toujours savoureux aime bien
[Musique]